was his forte against uh korean
christoph and you can see the players
have kicked off and duda has gone for a
very solid opening the patch of defense
yeah and it feels like duda after the
kind of roller coaster of the last two
games that emotional journey that he
went on winning twice in a row actually
leading in today's match he's taken
uh to step back he's going back to his
favorite opening repertoire he plays
this opening the petrol of opening when
he just wants to draw so duda is just
trying to be as solid as possible
and uh look how symmetrical the position
is right now once the black king castles
this is still quite well known um this
position and duda using that solid
repertoire the problem for duda maybe is
that magnus carlsen prepared this a lot
during the world championship match
against yandere pontiac who was also
reliant on the petrov defense so
okay some pieces coming off potentially
in the next few moves i actually studied
this position just two weeks ago i was
planning to play it from the black side
but it felt a bit miserable black is
fighting for equality because white's
piece is slightly better placed
especially the white rook on the central
file white star squad bishop about to
jump out as well and uh yeah i just felt
a bit uncomfortable from the black side
when i was studying this but duda look
at the speed he's been playing at 16
minutes
it looks like he's very very confident
magnus meanwhile the question for him is
not just the position on the board which
is roughly balanced uh for magnus it's
all about recovery trying to get back
kind of on a stable mindset as quickly
as possible he nearly never loses twice
in a row ivanka and i were just
discussing as well maybe we can only
remember one or two occasions in which
magnus has lost two games in a row
he's in unfamiliar territory the world
champion and this game
he needs to try and put some pressure on
nice to try and win but
it's not going to be easy especially if
he can't recover okay meanwhile we did
see a trade of one side of bishops and
white's queen now attacking blacks
knight
so uh that black knight can move or it
can be defended by a pawn for example
and this position yeah still relatively
balanced the knight does move but magnus
he will try to create some imbalances a
bit later on by pushing pawns he's
getting ready to do that this pawn push
just supports another pawn push next to
it on the c file white's pawn will throw
foot itself forward two squares there
and
this is maybe a magnus type of position
more than a duda type of position in
general so i like the opening choice for
magnus but
it's still early days black is rock
solid
at the moment yeah and i have to say
that uh this little porn move has
actually never been played before has
been analyzed in 2021 could have been in
november 2021
you never know by magnus's uh team or
maybe magnus himself who knows it could
have been by his team so i mean this is
the idea you know just to control the
circuit of the knight sitting
on the d6 square but uh dude he just
continues with his development and i do
feel that white's position like you say
is slightly more comfortable
yeah it's not a big thing here we're not
looking for big advantages there won't
be any incredible spectacular kind of
direct attacks like we saw uh duda uh
kind of win the last game with but
magnus he'll just be looking for those
tiny little uh kind of
progress uh progression signs he'll just
be stepping one port forward here and
there one knight forward in there the
knight on the edge of the board for
black maybe he'll try and control that
piece a few uh small things but maybe
that they'll add up to something bigger
later in the game and uh i can tell you
that on social media there are quite a
few people very excited for young
christoph duda you know they're really
cheering for him and this big comeback
that he is making and uh i just want to
share with you a selfie from dmitry
stanislav who asks the question what if
jan kristoff wins again
amazing evening
uh yeah absolutely if he wins again it
will be the first ever tie breaks we've
seen on the melt water champions chess
tour incredible 2022.
uh can you believe that we haven't seen
a single tie break and there's been
quarter final semi-finals it's been
pretty decisive so far it's about time
yeah and it would be nice if it actually
went the whole way
to armageddon and it's very critical
because there
magnus actually gets to choose what
color pieces he has that's true and we
have seen you know that some people have
chosen the black pieces to have less
time but uh the quick players they
always choose white
and magnus is a quick player and
actually young christopher only needs to
draw in this game
to take us to those tie breaks and duda
just looking off to the right there
looking off at the ceiling doing a bit
of a beth harmon that's because he's
trying to remember uh what to do in this
position i'm pretty sure both players
have studied if not this exact position
than something
pretty similar
so
yeah he'll be familiar with the ideas
the black knight on the edge of the
board can for example step back and just
go and recentralize itself i've seen
duda do something actually very similar
in almost an identical position the
black knight can also jump forward just
to attack the white queen but the knight
will also be driven back there
i do remember quite a recent game
actually between dominguez and duda not
using this move this poor move that you
mentioned magnus chose but dominguez
actually beat duda there in quite
convincing fashion
so duda has mixed experiences with this
opening
and yes black is solid but you need to
be accurate still because also white
knights they might look innocuous at the
moment but they could go towards the
black king
black's king lacking defenders
there are some when i was analyzing this
this opening there are some variations
where black has to find a series of only
moves just to survive on the king side
and were there natural moves no that's
why i chose actually it was in the final
round or the penultimate round in my
match against neil's grandelias uh i had
been suffering as black throughout that
entire match against nils and i thought
okay maybe the petrov defense just be
rock-solid try and uh hold the draw
there because a draw would have suited
me i was in the lead but
no uh i just wasn't brave enough this
type of position i thought was too
difficult for black to handle and magnus
meanwhile making his making his move he
pushes forward he's asking real
questions of duda this is another
trademark move from magnus you know he
loves to just see space uh on the wings
and he just likes to advance those pawns
forward he's very much a maximalist and
he really goes after this really good
pawn structure where he controls the
breaks and he is the one in uh full
uh control of how to push and when to
push ah it's a nice strategy if i were
duda what would you do if i would do
that i probably would capture the pawn
yeah dude has got an unpleasant decision
it's a bit of a dilemma if you capture
this pawn as you mentioned ivanka which
is very natural then white just replaces
that with a pawn and white will have two
pawns in the center of the board black
will have none so you lose some central
influence the other option
also not ideal because white now at some
point maybe we'll see a trade of rooks
first but white does have the option of
stepping forward with the pawn hitting
black's knight in the centre of the
board white gains space there i know you
like that structure uh quite a lot your
anchor white can gain space also as you
mentioned white does hold the key if
magnus only needed to draw he probably
wants to win but then at some point
later we would see a trade of pawns in
the center white is the one who can
unlock that central tension any time he
wants dude meanwhile with this bishop
retreat that's a passive piece and i'm
expecting i was going to say magnus
before just deciding what to do with his
pawn structure there just to develop a
piece uh develop his bishop and he kind
of keeps uh judah guessing
is he going to push forward with the
pawn that's something that
duda doesn't necessarily have to
calculate but he has to assess yeah and
every turn for the next five six moves
duda will have to assess as you
mentioned that white sea pawn stepping
forward one square also look at the two
black knights one of them is going to
get attacked in a moment maybe by a pawn
the other knight on the edge of the
board now can't jump forward because
this white bishop controls it
so that white that black knight might be
forced to take a step back i'm expecting
duda to do that maybe now or the next
couple of turns and uh tristan from the
same country as young christopher duda
poland donated twenty nine dollars
manuel from uh spain donated 48 dollars
we are getting so close you guys to our
goal of 150 000 in our fundraiser for
unicef
not much time left to uh raise that
money so please donate if you can and uh
in the auction only two and a half
minutes left on our two items to sign
chessboard by magnus carlsen current bid
5100 this is a unique item signed by
perhaps the best uh chess player in
history and also our other signed item
the air things device also signed by
magnus current bid
1025 dollars two minutes left to make
your bid and thank you to everyone who
is participating both in the fundraiser
and in the auction
all of the money goes to unicef's
life-saving work in ukraine so thank you
to everyone and here goes harry here
comes harry
and uh no harry's not meeting sally this
time harry's going to meet the black
king
and uh magnus is pushing harry the
h-born towards that black king and first
he's pushing back the black knight wow
magnus you mentioned the word maximalist
ivanka he's seizing space on both flanks
both sides of the board uh this black
knight now
looks like it has to retreat it's going
to a bit of a sad square now
maybe near the black king and then white
is going to push on both flanks both
sides of the board black is gonna be
really cramped and
this is the one thing i will mention
duda he had a success against magnus in
the last two games by playing really
dynamic really kind of firebrand type of
chess
but he's gone back to a really solid
passive approach this opening is
designed for black purely to achieve a
draw and it doesn't suit his style uh
he's got to a decent level in world
chess a very strong level by kind of
playing the pattern of defense
occasionally kind of taking these really
passive negative decisions but he looks
so uncomfortable every time i see him
play the petrov every time i see him
kind of grovel for a draw it's just not
him
he may be
feeling a bit more uncomfortable now
maybe regretting his opening choice it
looks very one-sided and it's a magnus
type of position as i mentioned more
than a duda type of position so uh yeah
i'm liking all these pawn pushes
normally you know me ivanka i have
commitment issues when it comes to pawn
pushes but here i love the fact magnus
is gaining space on both flanks because
duda will be stretched later okay he
jumps in sacrificing a pawn i was going
to say he will be stretched with his
defenses guarding both both sides so
wait one second can you just
not grab that pawn yeah and it's a trick
there is a trick isn't it so we do have
to show that right so uh the whole point
is that the queen
there on d3
isn't protected loose pieces drop off
and you might be asking yeah but the
line isn't open so why is why is that
relevant but after knight takes night
pawn takes knight and if you do capture
the pawn rook takes pawn then uh you can
play knight takes pawn
really nice trick here this is actually
a fork whoops not there
attacking the queen attacking the rook
and uh the pawn cannot obviously capture
the black knight because the white queen
drops off behind it so actually as your
vancouver mentioned once things open up
this pawn in the center is pinned it's
as if it's not there and the other key
detail is that after knight takes born
white can give a check maybe magnus was
relying on this one but this check can
be met with a night block so no time to
capture the black knight and after white
brings the rook across it looks deadly i
think magnus was relying on this winning
the black knight on the next turn and
the black king doesn't really want to
come out of its hiding place as a
defender maybe what magnus missed is
that the black pawn can step forward
here counter-attacking against the white
queen kicking it off the same diagonal
as the black king and duda just about
it's really scary it's by the skin of
his teeth but just about safe in this
position so
um actually backtracking just a few more
moves uh here when we while i was
praising pushing harry the h pawn
forward maybe magnus missed a trick not
pushing this guy forward now it might
have been a bit different and then only
next move pushing
on the h file but uh duda yeah this is
why uh he's got to the top of world
champs he's really tricky uh it's very
hard to kind of control a game against
him because he always finds these small
tactics and uh yeah this pawn maybe it
can be captured maybe you're right
ivanka because knight takes knight as
mentioned rook takes is met by this
really cool move knight takes pawn and
suddenly somehow black is just about
okay yeah
nice line there and uh very neatly
calculated by duda
and uh well ben degroot
noticing that magnus looks much more
stressed than duda right now and also
includes a selfie
and
scott b robinson well he's still team
magnus he says go team norway and he's
actually wearing one of these
traditional norwegian jumpers but with a
chest design they were actually made
that's actually the norway chess jumper
yeah yeah
and they made ones they make a jump
especially for norway chestnut very very
cool very cool
and uh finally we do have while the
players are waiting we do have a meme
this time from rishab shah who says the
tables have turned suddenly and there
you see
looking all fierce and there you see
magnus
[Laughter]
we do like memes
we even don't mind them if you make them
of ourselves yeah isn't that right david
uh yeah
whether i want them or not
we had some fantastic memes after uh
david beat magnus at 10 years old in our
charity challenge
and uh i also saw some gifts of that
reaction
incredible stuff i loved your reaction
there thank you kaia and maybe we'll see
a reaction from one of these two players
whoever wins this match because it's
suddenly really tense yeah they're going
to be exploding with joy
later on so
yeah i mean
duda with his last move
he's made me think that we might be
headed towards tie breaks just a really
cunning idea then look at magnus
frustrated i think magnus is regretting
as i just mentioned he could have
kind of changed the move order of his
last two moves and he would have taken
away this defensive resource from duda
and duda would have been purely on the
defensive it would have been quite
one-sided i think magnus would have had
a huge advantage there but uh yeah if
you just stop focusing for one second
against duda he will be able to trick
you he will be able to kind of change
the momentum he's very very good at that
uh in a game and
yeah maybe he'll be the one exploding
with joy if
celebrating if he wins this or holds
this game i can't remember ever seeing
young christophe duda sort of explode
with emotions because mostly i've seen
him uh winning an over the board chess
so that could be the reason but i'm
wondering you know if he wins this match
now
oh yeah if i would be curious to see how
he reacts if he won the whole event
would be cool with him reaction chess
thumping some kind of yes or would he
just kind of give us a little
i did it yeah
somehow i suspect that
part of his success as a chess player is
because he keeps his emotions on the
check
because you know emotion okay we have
seen a capture of the central pawn and
so now we're expecting doodle to
actually just
take the pawn with a knight
black's knight on the edge of the board
has to improve itself and
not only can it step back it can take a
pawn in the process and this exact
variation this key line uh that we
showed this is the acid test of what
duda had planned and there was so much
pressure on the diagonal that you have
to drive back the white queen so that
pawn pushed white's queen has had to
retreat and
magnus does have some hints of an attack
maybe against the black king at some
point utilizing this e-file and that is
neutralized by duda his knight retreat
really really nice strategy there
if all the rooks disappear i think
black would be safe also white has an
isolated pawn in the middle of the board
so long term black has decent chances
but magnus decides okay he has to keep
at least one set of rooks on the board a
trade of one pair is inevitable as we
see there one set of rooks disappearing
but magnus with one rook at least can
focus on some weak pawns and another
very typical magnus move probing for
some weaknesses trying to
test his opponent's kind of
understanding of pawn structures just by
pushing a pawn here i don't think black
necessarily wants to trade this set of
pawns off because that would open up
further lines for white's pieces
so yeah really tense now it's definitely
balanced i could go either way but uh
duder survived the opening yeah he has
survived the opening and i actually
think black has a great position i would
be very satisfied here i mean the only
thing that that would concern
me if i had the black pieces although
it's fully under control right now is
that the black king is marginally open
you know it's unexposed diagonal
but
great night great defensive bishop
bishop is working well on its starting
square ironically enough and uh the rook
is ready to get into the game and it has
uh some potentially very exciting open
lines and uh yesterday i'm still
still made a huge impression of me uh
what pontus said about teaching chess
and how in some places in africa they
teach the chess pieces and how they move
yeah and they liken them to animals and
i i i love that the rook is the rhino
and it just like stampedes across a
brilliant analogy oh yeah i agree
to uh to have the pieces be animals not
only the knight the horse but all the
other pieces as well it might be time
for that rhino to
step up and you know start stampeding uh
black's rook i'm expecting it to
centralize itself bring itself the whole
way across there we go and attack
white's queen also the most natural move
in the position uh black now forcing the
white queen back i'm not sure which
direction magnus will choose i'm
assuming it will go back and line itself
up with the rook there we go and black's
rook now rock solid this rhino holding
the position together and uh yeah magnus
is running out of ideas here maybe he's
created a few threats over the last few
turns but dude uh holding everything
with his pieces and the one problem here
i see for white uh you know me if you've
anchor white knight is a bit stuck so uh
at some point magnus needs to improve
the white knight notice how the black f
pawn on the f6 square controls every
square the white knight wants to jump
into at least in the black half
so just a very good strategy as well
there duda to control white's knight and
its energy
the white knight i'm expecting at some
point to go off to the h4 square behind
harry the h pawn just to re-centralize
itself later on that's actually a kind
of maneuver magnus also used in the
world championship match but this one
could turn duda has asserted full
control and if magnus can't find
anything over the next two or three
moves black is the one who can start
thinking about a long-term advantage
and uh we see allen from canada donating
33 dollars i also saw apple from finland
and we've seen many people from finland
donating in our fundraiser for unicef
and we're so grateful for that and uh it
shows we have a lot of finnish viewers
are there a lot of finnish grand masters
that you know about
uh i can think of a couple yeah uh one a
very famous one is high key restaurant
ah um yeah haiki is a he's actually a
frequent visitor to norway and he was
once arrested
for
for spying
but he wasn't but he wasn't spying he
was just going for a walk in the norway
it was a chess tournament there with a
colleague and uh they were just like
stumbling across they were just like
losing themselves in thought and just
going for this walk between games and uh
the police were like hang on a second
what's he doing here this is military
operations so yeah he got arrested and
they were like well he's just player so
then let him out oh wow what a story
i remember first meeting hiki western uh
when i was really young i think i was
like 10 11 years old and i thought wow
this guy's old
but he was a great chess player and he's
still going strong i still see him
occasionally playing in the tournaments
how cool yeah so yeah um some great
finish players
yeah big hello to finland yeah and uh to
everyone also donating you can still
donate we are aiming for 150 000
use this qr code or uh
uh go to um what is it chess24 dot com
forward slash donate
there you have it all right a couple of
moves a couple of moves and uh actually
black's queen
bit sneaky that brought itself to the
top of the board eyeing up white's h
pawn the white pawn on the edge and
white had to defend it white's queen
reactivating itself but that has allowed
black to dive into the position with the
black rook this rook on the second rank
we love rooks on the second rank in
general especially if you're black the
seventh ranked for white but here the
black rook attacking a couple of things
that are defended currently so
i must admit i'm a bit surprised by this
one i think dude's idea at some point is
to bring the black queen down and off uh
offer up a trade of queens but uh
white's king for example can try to
evict this black rook
uh i'm expecting magnus now justice
there we go taking the words out of my
mouth again and uh now there's some
pressure on the black rook the black
queen is a bit overloaded right now
defending its rook defending some pawns
so i'm expecting the rook to retreat and
duda
okay maybe just
accepting his last move wasn't that
effective he just forced magnus to burn
a little bit of time and waste a little
bit of
kind of energy deciding what to do with
the white king and uh just deciding okay
time to retreat
and nothing nothing wrong with that no
harm done to black's position yes you
lost a couple of moves but white not
gaining too much in the process white
tonight now as i as i mentioned needs to
relocate itself um the dance that magnus
did with his knight started with this
move and then it kind of came back to
the g2 square and then re-centralized
itself that's what he did against
napoleji in the same opening actually in
the petrov defense from last year's
world championship match yeah so maybe
it's a good idea for
duda you know just to actually step
forward with the rook and attack the
dark square bishop
or is this a little bit problematic
yeah it looks definitely possible the
black rook just doing a bit of a yo-yo
just dropping down then going up
dropping down then going up
so blackstroke could come down to the
second rank now that white's knight has
kind of gone away as you mentioned
ivanka from the defense of his bishop
white's bishop is loose and
as we've seen a couple times today loose
pieces are big targets
i heard that yo-yos they come back in
out of fashion every five years okay
yeah and i think it's actually correct i
have like a yo-yo hang up every like
five here this year
it was really popular when i was a kid
yeah yeah i mean we had these kind of
like
um this uh the coca-cola company used to
used to kind of sell one with fanta one
was bright and we were crazy about it
and we collect them and we do all these
kind of tricks and we thought it was so
cool and then i remember one was walk
the dog yeah i could do this one yeah
maybe that should be our next challenge
you guys
where you build it and then you just
goes in and out of there no
oh that's a cool one too now you
literally just yeah it rolls on the
floor basically yeah and then you kind
of pick it up and yeah anyhow okay i
have a i put my money on your manko
winning our yoyo challenge
it's been a long time since i've done
these things you know so he comes back
you know
is it like riding a bicycle yeah i
haven't even ridden a bicycle for a long
time for me too actually
no secret guys my deepest darkest
dirtiest secret you don't know how to
work i don't know how to ride a bicycle
is that i've never sat on a bicycle uh
in my life apart from at the gym where
it's fixed so
one day one day wow anyway oh no that's
oh no i shouldn't have said anyway
that's not gonna be a challenge we're
gonna go back to the position because we
saw a couple of moves sidestepping and
white's queen retreating there was a bit
of tension there some indirect threats
against white's queen and magnus just
trying to maintain control it's still
very cagey still balanced
but uh neither side flinching or giving
way so far well something that is going
completely crazy is the auction for the
signed chessboard current bid 8
400
uh i think there are a couple of people
in a big fight to get their hands on
this unique historical chessboard
and all money will go to unicef so it's
for a great cause as well
uh currently four minutes left whenever
someone makes a new bid a little more
time is added
but i'm just gonna say thank you to uh
the people in uh that fight to get their
hands on that chessboard
cool
that's insane thank you yeah i have to
give everyone who's contributed everyone
who's bid on any one of these objects
you know thank you so much thank you for
being part of this chess community
to do something noteworthy to do
something amazing for the children and
the people of ukraine absolutely you
know it means so much
i really am touched
i agree it's uh fantastic what we've
seen from the chess community over there
well basically over the last month after
the crisis in ukraine 147
is currently what we have been able to
fundraise for unicef our goal is a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
uh
we have a move is still still kg or a
little unsurprised yeah still cagey but
i think magnus will be happy with the
developments over the last move it
hasn't changed the evaluation too much
but i'm surprised to see duda retreat
his knight and also white's bishop which
was a bit of a i don't want to say
useless piece but a bit of a limp piece
there not really doing too much it has
some threats it wants to eliminate the
black knight one thing white would love
to do is trade his bishop for the black
knight black's knight is the key piece
duda cannot allow that piece to be
exchanged but if we jump in magnus has
kind of tricked duda and it was just
because duda i think was at a loss of
what to do maybe duda could just sit
still um i know his queen just came from
the square but he could retreat the
queen just say okay i've built this kind
of wall this barrier you're not breaking
through and i think magnus would have
run out of ideas but he stepped back
with the knight maybe trying to attack
this pawn and now magnus has said you go
backwards i go forwards something i
picked up from your banker and uh the
white bishop has gone forward previously
it couldn't do this and now it's
guaranteed to trade itself off that was
white's worst piece is going to trade
itself off either for black's very
strong knight or the bishop behind it
and
the reason this is possible is because
if judah grabs this pawn now then
white's bishop will jump forward make
this exchange and after a trade we could
see a couple of moves for example white
can take this pawn or i can even jump in
with his knight first and suddenly i
think black would be a bit nervous the
queen has to retreat she's on the fire
and suddenly some big attacks coming
against the black king maybe black's
okay here some calculation needed but
black is really playing with fire the
queen and the knight combined
threatening checkmate and remember that
rhyme knights on f5 will thrive it's
coming into effect now and uh i don't
think duda should grab this pawn i think
he will live to regret his greed if he
does take it i think maybe it's time to
start thinking about bringing the knight
back to the center but again similar
problem uh we will see a trade of
bishops and at some point white tonight
will re-enter the fray using this great
f5 square
yeah
i was i was just thinking about this
position and i agree with you completely
it was the wrong piece to retreat
and i agree i think that uh duda just
miscalculated i think somehow in his
head he just thought well you know
i will capture the pawn and he totally
forgot that
bishop takes knight and his pawn on also
on c6 is hanging and the white knight is
an amazing piece especially in
conjunction with the queen so i mean
it's it's not
it's not a great choice
and i think it's just it's this is what
happens when you slip up we see kind of
like small inaccuracies and the
opponents have been given
a chance to make life uncomfortable and
we've seen queen takes porn you said you
should not do that david i mean maybe
he's okay we'll see uh over the next few
moves but this one he's got to walk a
tightrope now he's going to be super
accurate on every move okay the
evaluation was slightly in white's favor
not too much i think his idea do that is
that if the white knight jumps in he
does have one move maybe that i
underestimated uh instead of the black
queen going back the whole way allowing
this type of attack that i mentioned
against the black king maybe his idea is
to try and trade queens and maybe he's
safe here the queen steps back now
offering up this trade of course and if
white does sidestep then turn around the
black queen can actually use the corner
square to deliver checkmate so uh
actually with this idea black can force
the queen's off and uh maybe with the
queen's off you can survive it's still a
bit scary for black to be honest uh just
because black has so many weak pawns and
also white's rook could enter the
seventh rank uh but maybe you're okay
here as black this bishop does defend
everything that this white knight will
throw at you
so okay maybe it's fine and in the
current position this has got to be his
idea duda stepping back with the queen
otherwise i do think he's in big big
trouble
he's got to seek solace in the end game
yeah
and uh yeah this is a really really
crazy position i was actually attracted
to just grabbing material
and then just kind of saying yeah you
know what the queen and knight better
than the queen and bishop simple chess
which was uh
also quite an
interesting approach
um instead i agree with you only really
one move to save the game and uh i do
have to share with you a tweet whilst
we're waiting for doodle to find the
queen stepping back to the d5 square and
it seems to me that pets are either like
the love they love chess or they hate us
and uh okay the queen does step back to
a critical square and asics machining
says
his dog is saying oh their dog is saying
please play with me instead of watching
chess
and it is cute
[Laughter]
yeah pets love chairs hey chess what do
you think
i hope most love chess
we do know a few chess players who do
love their pets as well so it's a mutual
kind of
relationship there mm-hmm
that's uh yeah i'm sorry
i hope that isn't feeling too left out
i'm not sure if either of these two have
pets i don't think magnus has any pets
no no
i'm not sure
it's difficult for chess players with
their lifestyle right traveling
traveling all the time um i mean you've
got to travel across the world regularly
not just for a couple of days it's two
weeks at a time three weeks at a time
these guys played at the world cup both
of their work uh both of the two players
they were uh in russia for almost a
month so
um yeah i mean it's just not
unfortunately fitting with the lifestyle
there are some exceptions however like
as we saw levon aronian very very uh
fond of his dog ponchick and wesley so
with his cats
dog and cat i think you need a good
support network a big family around you
to look after the pets when you're on
the road
uh when you're on the tour
so
okay
ah neither of these two players uh i
think at the stage where they
uh i mean they're just fully focused on
chess basically i don't think they have
uh time unfortunately for pets right now
and uh the clock is ticking for magnus
this is a super dramatic game magnus
carlsen he has to win it if he wants to
avoid tie breaks any other result means
we will head to target to decide the
winner of the charity cup but i'm also
keeping my eye on
our charity auction nine seconds left on
the chessboard current bid 8600
and i'm just updating to see if that
will be the final bid because i know
there is a little bit of a battle going
on okay now it says closed auction
meaning the signed chessboard by magnus
carlsen
finally went for eight thousand six
hundred dollars all money going to
unicef i mean that must be the most
expensive chessboard ever
yeah impressed and we're just lucky to
have such generous viewers it's going to
a good cause of course and yeah i mean
the chessboard in your home is going to
be
great talking point
yeah that's incredible i wonder if they
will actually play on it or if they will
be like on the wall yeah
um how will it be used well
congratulations anyway to the one who uh
eventually won this auction getting an
historical piece a very unique
chessboard signed
by world champion magnus carlsen
wow impressive stuff all right we do
have a few moves on the board we do have
a few moves as mentioned the queens were
destined to trade off for each other
there was no way magnus could have
avoided that as we showed there was a
nasty checkmate if magnus had run away
from a queen trade and that meant that
black was able to escape in the end game
and black is one pawn up temporarily
magnus can go and win a pawn back with
his rook at some point in the near
future first he has to remove his knight
and remember magnus for him a draw is
the same as a loss so he might as well
keep pieces on the board
trading his night off for the black
bishop would have just ended in a dead
drawn rook game so magnus tries to keep
his winning chances his tiny slim
winning chances alive by keeping this
knight versus bishop in balance and uh
what do you think ivanka knight over
bishop we've talked about that a few
times this tournament yeah it's been a
common theme actually every single day
it's been like which one is better the
knight or the bishop in this particular
case i have to say i do quite like the
night
but
it's only because you know the rook
white's rook is so active and also white
has a
very dangerous past pawn on the edge of
the board and i can see a scenario where
this is going to be something that
troubles duda considerable
yeah the big question is should black
get greedy here and temporarily go two
pawns up
could black get greedy and maybe even
push the black b pawn down one square uh
big decision for duda not much time to
make it but let's quickly jump in just
to show how both sides are going to try
and uh end this game duda wants to trade
off these two pieces and then he's safe
even if magnus wins his pawn back as
long as it's level number of pawns if
these pieces disappear duda will never
ever lose but it's not easy to do that
if you chase the knight away bring your
bishop in for example the white knight
can move you can even maybe flick in an
annoying check first
this has happened i was gonna say the
other option push this pawn down keep it
alive just a little bit longer uh but
again maybe this pin just too annoying
on the seventh rank and uh the third
option would have been getting greedy
and taking this pawn with the black
brook but this was playing with fire the
blackrook offside for a few more moves
so duda decided to indeed challenge this
white knight in the center trade it off
to get safe uh get safe and closer to
the draw but white's saying no the
knight jumping forward and you have to
be a bit careful with this black rook
right now you don't want to slide it
back one square attacking the knight
because you have to look out for night
forks don't keep your pieces too close
to your king when a knight is on the
board because a check and a fork wins
the black rook so that being said uh
duda has to decide what to do i was
going to say maybe now is the time to
capture this pawn he says no he goes and
challenges uh magnus to defend the f2
point in front of the white king how to
guard this there's no way to protect it
you have to advance this pawn and magnus
steps his pawn forward now duda surely
before this root gets trapped it's
running out of escape squares maybe it's
time to go and grab uh harry grab the h5
pawn at least then after you do take it
you do have an escape route with the
black rook yes the pawns on the other
side will fall as a consequence but i
think this bishop you can find a safe
square for it maybe just drop it back
one square and uh
yes the black rook might look a bit uh a
bit clumsy in this type of position but
black is upon up
so
still very very tense in the position
magnus taking big risks to try and win
this game wow he wants to avoid tie
breaks actually do you but will he be a
big favorite and high breaks with faster
time controls or is young christoph duda
a player that can uh you know play some
nice blitz chess as well she can
definitely play some good blitz chess
i've played him a few times online and
blitz dude and he's really dangerous
it's so hard to avoid his tactics
i think strategically magnus is far
better in blitz but
it's hard with no time on the clock to
contain your opponent's
activity and also remember these guys uh
kind of forted out for a world blitz
title a few years ago uh both sides were
kind of chasing each other magnus was
half a point ahead with like eight games
to go seven games to go and then they
both won the remaining games dude was
chasing him the whole way and duda got
silver at the world blitz championship
so
one of the best blitz players in the
world is going to be especially if he
holds this game the momentum is on
dude's side as well absolutely
wow well we did
announce that the chessboard was sold
for eight thousand six hundred dollars i
was wondering is it the most expensive
chessboard in the history answer is no
of course uh there is a chat set made
from 18 karat white gold insert with
more than 500 carats of diamonds
and some you know bunch of diamonds and
stuff uh
priced at four million dollars it's a
little bit more expensive but i mean
this one uh in a few years could be
worth so much money with the signature
of magnus carlsen you might have you
might have gold and diamonds but it's
not signed by magnets exactly and i also
googled
the most expensive assigned items in
history
george washington's act of congress
9.8 million dollars a little bit more
expensive but in 10th place uh a signed
newspaper by john f kennedy 39 000
i mean we're not too far behind
no
actually not eight thousand not that far
behind
thirty nine and as and as the chess gets
more and more popular you know the value
of the signature
exactly
ah definitely magnus's legacy is just
starting it feels like i mean still got
many years at the top already one of the
greatest players in history
yeah huge congratulations to whoever won
the auction and thanks to everyone who
participated
a bunch of moves the big question can
magnus cross and win this game any other
results and we will head to tiebreak
he's trying his best he's doing some
really weird and wonderful stuff magnus
he's put his knight on the top of the
board
your ankle you're frowning at me i don't
like it at all i mean for for white i
mean look at it now the rook has come
down to the second row king is cut off
the knight and the rook not dangerous at
all and i think
that it is uh the white pawn on b3 which
i kind of thought wow that's going to be
an ass one day and actually the players
are probably going to be we're about to
see a result it is a draw magnus on the
brink of defeat there actually he took
the draw and we are headed to tie bricks